Speaker 1: We have some really great discussion
happening on The David Pakman Show sub Reddit
and some not so good, which I will point to
today.
You can find the sub Reddit at David Pakman
dot com slash redit.
That's our edit.
Here's a post I spotted this morning and this
is really sad.
A user illustrious Worth writes, My father
is a right wing conservative and he's too
deep into McGartland.
He's even trying to drag me into it.
What can I do to get him out?
I should probably explain further.
They write.
The majority of my family members are Democrats
and my father is pretty much the only Republican
in the family.
He's been making me listen to conservative
radio for the past few months so he can, as
he puts it, give you a different perspective.
He does listen to me and my opinions from
time to time, but he's the dominant one when
it comes to political issues.
I'm going to try to make him watch an episode
of Dave's radio show.
I think that means me or at least listen.
But I understand that he may not change his
view instantly.
This is a really tough thing and this is affecting
a lot of families.
And in terms of advice and programing people,
as I've said before, I don't know what the
wholesale strategy is for deprogramming.
Nearly 75 million trumpet's.
I don't know what that is.
They seem really strongly programed.
It's resistant to change that programing.
But the best way is if you have the time,
individual relationships over longer periods
of time.
It's a lot of work, but it's starting to talk
to your dad about how did he come to the conclusions
that he came to?
How does he determine that something is true
in something they should believe?
What does it mean to them that they believe
that's how the world is?
Or what would it mean to them if the reality
was different than that which they believe?
This can be a big revelation to a lot of people
where they say, oh, there's a reason why I'm
so attached to this belief, because if I didn't
believe it to be true, it would change my
perspective of this, that the other thing
this is really, really tough.
But to be honest, if you're willing to put
in the work the best way the the the retail
strategy of building a relationship with someone
and talking to them over months and months
and examining where their beliefs come from
and where their news comes from, it's one
of the only ways that you can really change
people's minds.
But it is a hell of a lot of work.
I don't envy that view or whatsoever.
Now, here's another one.
I don't like this at all.
I've said before on the show, tell me why
I'm wrong about the things I actually say.
Tell me where I'm wrong about the things I
actually believe.
But one of the things I am disgusted by the
most is people who get mad at me about things
I didn't say.
And someone posted a Reddit thread about my
view on masks that is not based in anything
I've actually said.
And the user writes Why David Pakman doesn't
like wearing a mask every time Mr. PIAC Maniac
talks about how he just follows the CDC guidelines
and how he doesn't wear it outside, gives
the impression he's disgusted with wearing
it.
No, no, I've never expressed that.
And in fact, all along I've expressed let's
do what the CDC is saying.
I'm not an anti a.m.
The viewer goes on to say, I get the impression
he doesn't fully understand that wearing a
mask can also protect you against catching
cold, cough, et cetera, from someone else,
as well as the seasonal influenza in the winter.
But he doesn't even hinted that being a useful
habit to adopt for U.S. society when seasonal
influenza comes.
This is the opposite of what I've said.
First of all, when it comes to outdoor masking,
people aren't catching the virus outside.
People aren't catching the flu outside.
People aren't catching colds outside.
People aren't catching cough outside.
And I've actually said it would be a really
interesting way to deal with flu if during
flu season indoors where people actually transmit
flu grocery stores or whoever said please
wear a mask, or if people just decided, hey,
you know what, the experience of covid is
going to tell me during flu season, I'm going
to choose to wear a mask indoors.
This person is criticizing me for a belief
that is the opposite of my belief.
They go on to say, why is it that these types
of entitled people such as David in the US
always feel their freedom is being violated
when they're asked to do something for someone
else?
Seems they just don't want others telling
them what to do.
You people in the US are way behind you.
It's almost like you're attacking me if as
if I were Rand Paul.
I have never made the freedom and liberty
argument about masks.
What I've said all along, as I've seen no
evidence that this is being transmitted outdoors.
But I'll wear it when the CDC says wear it
outdoors.
When the CDC said you don't have to wear it
outdoors, I said that makes sense to me.
I will follow the CDC guidelines and no longer
wear the mask outdoors.
It's not about freedom.
I've always said I'm part of the team.
I will do what needs to be done if this is
what we're doing right now to show that we
are participating in the effort to to defeat
the virus, then I'm absolutely going to go
ahead and do it.
Guys criticize me for things I've said, not
for things I haven't said.
OK, join the discussion at David Pakman dotcom
slash Reddit.
That's already it.